moving over to Tennessee
well we've got the the bill here in
Tennessee which also is going to
um is going to ban the castration
mutilation of children
there's also there's another bill that's
making its way through uh the the
through the process right now to become
law and that is a bill to criminalize
well it's it's what we're being told is
that it criminalizes drag shows or drag
shows for children which it does
but that's not
what the bill is solely focused on what
the bill actually does is it
criminalizes sexual performances for
children of any variety
okay so you can't hold any kind of
sexual performance and involve children
in it
um now on on the left and the Democrats
in Tennessee they have taken that to be
an attack on drag in particular which
like what does that tell you
when you say you know what we should ban
sexual performances for children and
they immediately respond by saying what
so you think the drag should be banned
oh so you're admitting that this is a
sexual performance for children huh
anyway WKRN uh here locally has a report
on that let's watch that
this room now
three today
also known as the bill to potentially
criminalize drag shows the bill went
before two different committees
including the criminal justice
subcommittee news 2's Chris O'Brien
brings us inside
the eyes Prevail the bill moves on if
you wish to be recorded as a no please
see the clerk in front of a packed house
the house criminal justice subcommittee
voted to advance a bill to potentially
criminalize certain drag shows and we
are fighting against a group of folks
who were set on hate but really have no
understanding of what this looks like in
in theory in practice multiple people
testified against the bill saying it
unfairly reprimands the lgbtq community
last week I went to a drag show and I
was forced to walk past a mob of masked
men with guns and swastikas to get into
that drag show but the sponsor of liquid
Madison County Republic that didn't
happen so that's a lie that didn't
happen a group with swastikas and guns
do we have a video of that any pictures
of that
whole group of Nazis with with swats
that goes outside the drag show
I mean if they're if there were any
swastikas which I highly doubt that
actually happened
um it's almost certainly that that's
going to be the left that has them but
you know that's almost certainly leftist
agitators who are you know walking
around with swastikas so they could try
to blame it on the right they they do do
that that's something that they do on
occasion but most likely that was just
made up anyway continue applicant
representative Chris Todd says his bill
has nothing to do with drag shows and
why are we targeting this one thing
thank you Mr chairman and so far Mr
chairman the only person that's
mentioned anything about drag has been
the representative from Knox County I
haven't said a word about that
Republicans did have some concerns
particularly on the vagueness of the
bill Tendencies on Miley Cyrus at
Bridgestone Arena
I've seen her there in the past myself
would that cross the line
could she be subject to a pair of
handcuffs based upon well I hope so
vagueness ultimately that answer would
depend on if this bill passes the full
legislature for now the bill rests with
the full criminal justice Committee in
Nashville Chris O'Brien
criminal justice
probably shouldn't bring kids so Miley
Cyrus show uh at least that might maybe
it's a Miley Cyrus show 15 years ago or
something it'd be one thing but in the
modern yeah who would bring
what Miley Cyrus the current day Miley
Cyrus you're gonna bring uh what you're
bringing a seven year old to that
if that's the if that's the the slippery
slope here
where now all of a sudden you can't even
bring kids to a Miley Cyrus show okay
good
what how is that some sort of like
horrifying dystopian reality
do you need a gift for Valentine's Day
well then you need genucel skin care for
the first time ever every order at
genucel.com from now until Valentine's
Day includes a free Beauty Box with two
luxury gifts there they just introduced
their new microbiome moisturizer which
uses the power of probiotics to Target
skin redness pesky wrinkles Fine Lines
patchy blotches and other signs of
premature aging these are the same
probiotics that are in your yogurt as it
turns out probiotics are not just good
for digestion they can have the same
nourishing benefits on your skin you can
see results in 12 hours or get your
money back guaranteed my talent manager
Tessa uses genucel under eye treatment
to help get rid of the bags under eyes
that she claims are my fault for working
her so hard right now you can get
genucel's most popular package for 70
off as well as your two free luxury
gifts visit genyourself.com Walsh and
get 70 off with your free gifts use code
wall should check out to have the supply
to your account that's genucel.com Welsh
genucel.com
now I think it's actually really easy
though to distinguish between something
like a drag show
um and uh you know a pop star musical
performance it would be pretty easy to
distinguish between those things
and I think even in the language of the
spill it succeeds in doing that but my
point is that if you were to accept the
slippery slope argument I don't see it
as a problem
to have some basic standards of decency
um
especially as it pertains to content
that that where children are involved
that's that's yes we should have that
historically in this country we've
always had that
it's only very recently where we've
decided that that well the government
has no role whatsoever in enforcing any
standards of decency at all
even when it comes to kids
and so if the sexual degenerates and
perverts want to expose themselves to
kids all day long and have sexual
performance of kids there's nothing we
can do because if we were to do anything
at all next thing you know we're in a
handmaid's tale like it's only it's only
very recently that people in this
country have become stupid enough to buy
an argument like that
foreign
now the the reporter there in the in the
news article is not being honest
uh what we hear is that uh is that the
sponsors of this bill claim that it has
nothing to do with drag shows and
they're not saying it has nothing to do
with drag shows they're saying it's not
specifically outlawing drag shows what
they're saying is it Outlaws sexual
performances for children
and if there's a drag show that falls
under that umbrella then yes it would be
banned
but this would also ban for example
um a burlesque performance with with uh
featuring women where children are
involved we ban that too
now you might point out that that's not
really happening that most of this stuff
is involving drag
but that only tells you something about
the people that are putting on these
shows that just tells you something
about drag I mean if if
the whole drag industry will come
crashing down if they aren't allowed to
involve children anymore well then it
sounds like the drag industry is is one
that should come Crashing Down
and they continue to tell on themselves
so much because they don't even a bill
like this that prohibits sexualized
performances for children
they don't the left they don't just
claim that it's anti-drag they say that
it's anti-lgbt
so if you want a bill that says
um you can't put on a sexual performance
for kids
you can't like
strip and tear clothes off in front of
kids
you can't have you can't bring your
sexual fetishes out and put on a
performance featuring them if you say
that then they say Well that's anti-lgbt
what are you saying about the LGBT
community
that
if we tell you that you can't sexualize
kids that it's somehow are are you
saying that this is uh that that
sexualizing children is a is a central
fundamental aspect of LGBT culture is
that what you're saying
because that would seem to be what you
are saying
if you are claiming that a bill Banning
the sexualization of children is
anti-lgbt
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]